ce bouchard bonjour bonjour merci de
nous recevoir chez vous le web y est
venu chez moi où la rivière des prairies
cool derrière vous très bel endroit
species a prôné xi et je te bel endroit
pour vivre la pandémie ouais
cette pandémie loca est épouvantable
pour les personnes âgées pour les vieux
vous dites dans un livre les yeux
tristes de mon camion vous dites c'est
une très belle phrase est l'enfant
apprend à marcher
le vieux apprend à s'asseoir puis vous
êtes dans les deux cas ça se fait avec
des larmes et un besoin de consolation
c'est très beau comme fera dieu sait
qu'on a eu besoin de console et pas mal
de monde de piotr merci pour modifier
vos comms france mais c'est aussi très
très vrai enfin on le prend dans nos
bords ont le console
on connaît tous ces paysans font les
protégeant des les vieux on sait pas
comment faire ce mais ils ont le même
besoin
ils ont le même besoin d'être touchée
d'être rassuré c'est très très dur de
faire des deuils de s'asseoir un
tintement des mises est dix fois pire
c'est le côté caché de la pandémie
la solitude dans la mort la solitude
dans la maladie la solitude dans la
solitude dans son âme
dans sa jambe dans son appartement
c'était assez particulier de ne pas
pouvoir se toucher tu chez les siens
c'est peut-être l'image doha qu'on va
retenir dans quelques années de ça les
gens qui sont morts sans pouvoir être
touché par ce qu'ils aiment l mais moi
je les ai vécu j'ai été frappé par la
pandémie je n'ai pas vu venir on a peur
on voit pour venir ces choses là il ya
six mois je perdais marie-christine
aymeric est-il de cette baisse de 15
heures au cerveau elle doit donc quitter
la maison ici en ambulance tout à fait
consciente sont allés au chum parce que
parce que c'était très compliqué ça ne
l'est au sud et la belge et promettent
de mourir ici donc on autour de tout
fait payer les morts si tous tous aussi
beaux sauf que pendant qu'elle est trop
chaud mais je ne pouvais pas la visite
et cause pandémie pendant qu'on peut pas
visiter
j'ai ma femme j'ai mon amour je mens
gratin moma complice ma partenaire ligue
qui est touché ou chemin et c'est à ce
moment là qu'elle a perdu ses fonctions
punitive
s'il est intervenu c'était plus elle
cette affaire s'était pas les revenus
mais aussi mais c'était pas c'était pour
elle ce que j'ai vécu ce qui a été une
surprise pour moi j'ai pas pu la quitter
au moment où elle quittait c'est vrai
mais tout le monde avec sur la route au
canada ce qui est des pertes comme ça on
n'avait pas prévu ce que le fait qu'on
peut pas la lui pital me tue vers
palaisien puisse faire pour les iem
mourir ça va mal
ça fait mal et vous dit à plusieurs
endroits parce que vous avez perdu votre
autre femme qui est décédée du cancer ou
le cas et vous connaissez la paire
depuis le 15 heures il est vrai je
connais sur les scénarios les poteaux
police ils sont si bien que le chevalier
puis vous parlez d'impuissance ou face à
ces pour le compagnon lamoureux qui est
à côté tu n'es rien qui ne peut rien
contre notamment le cancer d'autres
maladies graves mais le cancer notamment
on ne peut rien faire et puis ça gêne le
vis encore marie partij si j'avais été
puissant si jamais tu épuisant
je leur ai retenu et vous
personnellement vous avez vécu cette
impuissance mais collectivement le vécu
on n'a pas pu console et nos vieux une
attaque inédite
ben pas inédites parce que dans
l'histoire on retrouve sais c'est que le
doivent souvent mais malgré nos
technologies malgré notre nom notre
savoir malgré la science malgré tout
cette affaire de frappe de plein fouet
nous ramène nous humilient d'une
certaine façon c'est sûr que on voit les
pleurs et nos morts des pleurs et de
mort les vieux c'est aussi la mémoire
enfin après ces faits la mémoire et vous
êtes puis ça traverse tous vos votes
écriture cette importance pour vous de
se souvenir de connaître l'histoire de
ne pas publicité camus quelques repris
mais de ne pas justement être étranger
dans sa société savoir le nom de l'arbre
de l'oiseau du fleuve
ça rappelle pas ce que j'observe que
sept empreintes
curieusement centenaire se perdent
ça vole
le nom des lieux est apprêté noms des
lieux arrivés en un lieu puis pourquoi
ça s'appelle comme ça et les vieux ont
un rôle à jouer là pour nous rappeler
les vieilles l'expression qui sont en
avance par être à jamais un canadien
français
j'aime tellement sort des expressions de
sa vieille langue mais on n'a pas plus
mais les vieux et les vieux je donne un
exemple je rencontrais un jour un
vieillard de 80 16 il y avait de l'air
d'un vieillard de 96 donc si typiquement
quelqu'un que replacer dans son siège
social 10 ans une chaise berçante qui
regarde le plafond ou l'ascenseur cet
homme était un vétéran de la guerre il
était mitrailleur sur les mains caste
mitrailleur de qu il a craché deux voies
de fait 36 missions est assis devant un
vieillard
là c'est la lancaster si la guerre c'est
les mitraillettes c'est les allemands ou
les nazis
c'est l'angleterre la résistance et de
toute l'histoire de notre saison mais
s'avoue facile mais ça nous obsède aussi
parce que vous dites est ce comme de
l'eau qui coule on perd mais on aurait
beau grand vous dites pour les jeunes ce
une station de métro le savent pas c'est
qu'ils honoreraient bulls vous en parlez
dans votre dernier pit pourtant ça
serait quelqu'un qui mériteraient ken
plaques ou moins devant le mettrons donc
ça vous obsède
oui ça m'a pesé de toute ma carrière
d'homme obsédé toute ma vie le manque de
d'orgueil de sensibilité comment
raconter notre histoire en fait la
première enfant et premier indignation
quand j'étais petit c'était l'histoire
du canada parmi les prêtres l'histoire
des prêtres qui raconte l'histoire du
canada scandale des générations de
dinyar des gens qui ont ignoré les
premières nations qui ont ignoré les
vraies natures des cons des grands
conflits mondiaux
going il a vraie découverte de
l'amérique et notre vraie identité à la
bd et tu sors première indignation ça a
été ça pour moi mais il ya une soif pour
ça parce que vous livre les oublier les
gens veulent sans ardemment donc on se
dit dans le système d'éducation il doit
avoir des lacunes quelque part que l'on
soit à ce point en tout cas mais
connaissant de certains personnages
extraordinaires mais mission d'éducation
dont ceux des normes soit j'ai beaucoup
de difficultés avec la clarté la de
décisions qu'ils prennent sur la nature
des programmes ça dure des décennies ça
dure vingt ans et l'histoire nationale
où l'histoire un enseignement de
l'histoire
ça reste quelque chose de très très peu
mieux les ajustements bien sûr on
n'enseigne plus que j'ai ce que j ai
pris un visage et un nom n'a pas
traversé le mur
on n'est pas arrivé et puis si les
débats sans fin sans dans un débat
public
donc si c'est carrément discussions sur
la culture qu'est ce qu'un être humain à
25,1 devrait savoir ils soient de
l'éducation
moi je pense qu'ils devraient savoir que
l'histoire de l'amérique comme du monde
sache bouchard votre capacité
d'émerveillement ça ça va jusqu'à la
toute dernière seconde
et là vous avez des bonnes questions du
bonne idée parce qu'effectivement c'est
vrai j'ai toujours cultivé madail éviter
rit jamais voulu développer du cynisme
de sueur de cynisme de fatigue
intellectuelle du tout c'est rare ça
vraiment cette extraordinaire là bien si
beaucoup géante à 73 ans puis je
soutiens afin qu ils capables de faire
un texte sur le poteau en avant de
téléphone exact je m'émerveille devant
tous mes savoure avait touché on avait
beaucoup touché là dessus mon père me
disait toujours qui est un journaliste
il n'y a pas de petits sujets qui vous
est tout sauf si la boue rien qui ne
vaut pas la peine d'être racontée dans
votre valeur à l'appui puis ça vaut pour
tout le monde
j'invite les gens cette naïveté à faire
le récit de leur propre vie où tout est
intéressant et je suis sg pas tout le
monde ne faut dire aussi que suit
anthropologue de terre dans ma vie j'ai
rencontré tellement elle chaque personne
ballet chi minh et l'histoire à mener
quelques jours nos souliers je suis
navré par les videurs voix bidon de
woippy dire quoi ça vous change parce
que l'essentiel pillon ça transparaît
dans votre dernier livre un café avec
marine c'est pas l'amour et je vous cite
une phrase que vous avez cru quand déjà
quatre as tu aimes le trottoir et
graviers dans la cour les j'ai perdu ton
père et l'auto noir de ton père syndic
un certain penchant en vérité durant
tant de toute ma vie j'ai simplement
aimer l'amour et j'ai mis de grands
élans d'à peu près
tous les regards oui c'est peut-être
conséquences parce qu'elle ment à
l'époque que j'ai vécu je faisais 250
aujourd'hui dans les années 60 il y
avait un désaveu du québec désire la
nature du québec t'intéresse personnel
les rocheuses on aime le colorado où on
aime les alpes mais québec
mais la nature on s'arrête dans son
détail on s'en va en abitibi on aperçoit
des épinettes noires puis on tombe en
amour avec les épinettes noires quand on
s'envoie au labrador canton s'envola
dans le coeur du québec quand on sent la
gaspésie et ceux dont on découvre des
potées innommable et j'étais là dedans
quand j'étais jeune j'étais là dedans
trouver la nature belle trouver les
leviers le québec botturi québec
intéressant comment maintenant vous
voyez cette vague dans l'est sur les
campus universitaire vous avez raconté à
la radio que ça vous est arrivé vous
quand vous avez prononcé le mot indien
il ya des jeunes qui vous ont fait la
morale qu'ils ont harangué presse est ce
que comme envoyer la suite de ceux des
balades sur les mots interdits parce que
des baux cruel et ses essais des signes
évidents dont il malheureux donc quand
on voit la décadence culturelle c'est ça
en fait nous conduit à quelque chose qui
très dur très inhumain qui qu'on ne
pourra jamais parler de personne sauf de
soi on ne pourra jamais parler de
personne sauf du jeu donc moi j'ai passé
ma vie à faire de l'appropriation
culturelle
donc je suis coupable donc je devrais
être réformé dans un goulag
quelconque ça ne vient des états unis
beaucoup il ya débat fait rage aux états
unis sur des mots à prononcer la
culpabilité des blancs des déblais du
quai la culpabilité d aucuns d'anglès
très fort aussi
c'est très très fort ces choses dont
canada le québec aurait aucune raison
d'en porter dans nos usines nos
universités des portes et moi
j'appellerai ce faux débat dans de
tristes aux arènes c'est à dire voyons
donc le mot [ __ ] une histoire dans la
littérature l'histoire dengue dans
l'histoire dans l'histoire des sociétés
le mot indien mon père parlait de
sauvages on ne peut pas oublier ça c'est
quoi société c'est isation des mots puis
de toute façon aujourd'hui on est rendu
tellement loin pour ne dire plus jamais
ces choses là on essaie de dire toujours
il faudrait se sont d ignaux vous savez
ce sont des attikameks tune attikameks
s'est fait insulter à joliette
c'est un micmac qui dit-elle chose à
propos des sig gauche
aujourd'hui on a pris nos noms des
nations on le dit à la télévision aux
narrations le répète grâce un peu a déjà
comme vivre c'est c'est l'ironie mais à
l'époque que ce soit enfin vous avez
fait le pont avec vous les aimez vous
voulez vous les respectez prochain deux
autres te fais tu devais j'ai consacré
ma vie à la promotion de la beauté des
cultures et des langues autochtones la
beauté des personnes cet automne serge
bouchard j'invite les gens à lire votre
dernier qui ne sera pas le dernier
un café non ce n'est pas le dernier
jamais ses dreads rodez a rien sans rien
me reprocher mais ils voulaient
immortaliser ben ali le texte le café
avec marie qui là dedans mais il y en a
d'autres textes celui là a été grêlée
radiophonique marité vivent donc être
connu ce texte qu'a fait avec
brazza vient de vieilles idées à une
amende jamais rien dans la vie c'est dur
à des caches se poser la question pas
journaliste
c'est quoi le bonheur pour vous durant
des caches puis là il sortit à café des
images comment n'a pas terminé là dessus
tout est dit serge bouchard merci
beaucoup mais c'est moi qui vous
remercie
oui